[Música]
hoje é meu colega carlos alberto falou
sobre o mapa pó bolacha unip e está a
mostrar as suas implicações
é na nossa opinião
ou seja foi que num dos motores é uma
revolução no microfone
na realidade há uma diferença muito
grande passo de uma escala menor
está dez metros e 10
[Música]
bom a gente sabe que o cobre
ele é dessa forma que o foco pedaço de
tronco de 17 e vários pedaços hoje
acrescenta ele
luz nessa cidade ele tem uma
característica é um ponto de fusão
caracteres acontece se a gente fizer uma
experiência metal em é e mais
preocupadas com um volume inicial
[Música]
eles não têm as mesmas propriedades do
maior milhão de vezes o banco de fusão
ele se altera no qual passa isolando e
parece ser aquela expressão é
completamente alterado com um propósito
é completamente diferente do mundo por
exemplo o brilho do sol é como explicar
o brilho do sol usando a pele da boca
bom eu vou falar um pouquinho sobre como
começou essa abertura já dura dois anos
e depois vou falar suas implicações
essa esse conjunto de conhecimentos ea
unidade adquirida
nós sabemos que o corpo até 70 ele mt
radiação bom de vista da física clássica
radiação ela tem um comportamento de
homens assim como a roda de tereré
[Música]
quando nós muito grande de jogos de
abertura noite rui pena de modo que a ua
a a2 está na ladeira da incidência está
bom e quando se foram usar o
conhecimento do mando 1909 física
clássica
[Música]
a previsão da imagem
definir o jogo
a candidata analistas vão se constituir
no judô a teoria conjunto beleza
bom então é que foi que os riscos é
sugerido e tem esse direito foi max
planck seu irmão na véspera do natal uma
derrota dentro de alguns desses dados em
30 do pacote é bom para toda a cidade
até então
ao sair ele não vai sair muito alto
confirmando os dados da onu
bom aí vem um amor grande mudança para
de um ano outra hipótese atentamente
fora do que estava estabelecido que a
matéria é bom dizer se há obviamente não
é uma onda de uma onda com a corda
nenhuma onda como está esse desenho
[Música]
fotografia e elas pois lá até 1024 é o
número um do outro
a largura
da mesma escada usada nesse estado ela
passaria a ter dez bilhões de vezes a
distância é só com 10 número número
impensável uma neta tem uma massa
extremamente comparado por exemplo com a
massa eo grão de areia muito inteiro e é
o maior número de manifestação do bom
2 essas duas derrotas
meira à noite ela tem características é
tem porta dentro também e de consumo e
que a matéria além do seu comportamento
enquanto se tenha uma conversa de homem
levaram a uma verdadeira revolução isso
eh eh nosso nome de física quanto todo
60 pulado a partir dessa ideia
pô quando ela teve o desenvolvimento
tecnológico é bom colocar a nu a placa
um chip do tamanho de 10 milhões de
doses
essa atualização é um fato bom então
isso é todo coberto das fibras óticas
nos computadores e celulares nos carros
autônomos
o dólar esta todas as marcas de
inteligência não existe o tempo é pouco
desse crescimento acumulado do ano susan
bom a gente tem vários avanços na
medicina de sj do ano o campeonato terá
direto porque na verdade mesmo
a meta é construir 1 com um microfone ou
a troca eu tenho a capacidade real mesmo
de alguns milhares de vezes provoca
tanta gente vai até às centenas de
milhares talvez um milhão e ao
transporte na realidade salienta que a
gente faça o pensamento biatletas de
trabalho atual
então isso permitiu por exemplo a
colagem porque no processo é preciso
estarmos em implantar de desenvolvimento
de um processo que leva tempo lá a 12
[Música]
trabalhamos na partida
trabalhamos por exemplo estudando é o
povo o sistema quanto à mostra de arte
de hidrogênio a ação e no buraco mesmo
objetivo
o objetivo de estudar e compreender a
filha do buraco deve fazer é uma maneira
indireta de ter acesso às informações e
provoca o processo acontece que nós
mudamos vá vá que não vá
[Música]
um dia ele pode ser utilizado pode ser
aproveitado a ideia é fazer da energia
desse papa significa que nós nos aguarda
pelas próximas dez mil jovens da nossa
mesa
[Aplausos]